[Music]
what's up minam to chime in on brown
[Music]
what have you brought to the show today
I'm here to show you the world's best
travel attire and I call it the
inflatable travel jumpsuit that's a lot
of adjectives exactly exactly
our brand is one-piece we're from Norway
we've been making these jumpsuits for
about 10 years I think we sold about 3
million of them a lot of people have
been like wearing these jumpsuits to
travel but it was never the perfect
travel outfit so we decided to develop a
product for the last three years that we
claim is the best travel attire on this
planet I know how to travel right right
what I'm going through Security's always
like a pair of joggers you know maybe I
heard it because I'm not trying to get
noticed by each and every person it's
always something there's just
comfortable because I figure it might be
a long flight and that's our mission
yeah everything we make is the most
comfortable thing you've ever put on I
have on one right now bro come on bro
stand up let me see what's going on
[Music]
I guess you're kind of wondering why the
word inflatable so we have some
inflatable components first thing right
here I'm just gonna blow into this valve
right here
[Music]
take your time we go there I have a neck
pillow right there just like that just
like that it's actually this piece right
here
ergonomically designed yes Wow now now
let me blow your mind okay so if that
wasn't enough we put on the hood all the
magic is in the hood so basically I'm
gonna blow in this valve and you just
open that up
[Music]
so it's made kind of like I would say a
onesie exactly the Marvel onesie I can
call it a jumpsuit yeah but like let's
say you get the burden of like a middle
seat or something you know yeah that
doesn't happen to me but I can
understand yeah so this like this right
here just ensures that you're
comfortable when you need to sleep you
need to sleep so we have this thing
right here this is the snooze cap I have
so much anxiety sometimes yeah and I
don't want to be the guy that's holding
everything up so I had these things
called fast-track pockets boom boom so
see I have my sunglasses right here and
my ear pods a toothbrush that we include
phone charger as cool bro I got my wok
and then for bigger items I have some
pockets down here as well if you uh I
got an iPad as a small in the copy of
the Forbes magazine and I got some candy
as well in case I'm hungry
oh this is inside your body there's
another pocket back here too
everyone asked me how in the hell do you
go in the bathroom in this thing
girls and number two it's always been a
bit difficult because so you have to
take off the jumpsuit and you hope that
the ground is clean but not anymore
because I this is called the rear exit
solution brother what is going on here
okay so you just go to the bathroom when
I zip yourself take a quick dip get up
zip yourself back up don't and good what
was something like this cost of people
$3.99 three's a 9 minnows that's cool
okay why is these for grownups come on
man